لقد كانت خطوة مهمة للأمام
بالسماح لهذه القافلة بالدخول ولكن أعتقد أنه تم توضيح الأمر بشكل
واضح للغاية، هل حدث
أي من ذلك مجرد قطرة في المحيط، وجاءت تلك الإمدادات
إليك وإلى
فريقك ولم تذهب هذه الإمدادات مباشرة
إلى مجمع تابع للأمم المتحدة ليتم توزيعها
بشكل أساسي إلى المستشفيات وإلى
المستفيدين الأكثر إلحاحًا والأشخاص المحتاجين
في منظمتنا والعديد من
منظمات الإغاثة الدولية الأخرى تنتظر
الفرصة لإحضار مساعداتنا الخاصة أه
من خلال المعبر المصري لدينا
شاحنات يتم تجهيزها الآن بالإمدادات
الغذائية الطبية  الملابس المائية وغيرها من
الضروريات الأساسية لمئات الآلاف
من الأطفال الذين ينتظرون
إما في ملاجئ الأمم المتحدة
كنازحين داخليًا أو أشخاص في
منازلهم المتضررة أو المدمرة في انتظار أي
نوع من الدعم، الغذاء ينفد،
الماء ينفد، الدواء
ينفد، لا يوجد  لا توجد كهرباء، لا توجد
مياه نظيفة، هناك مياه صرف صحي في
الشوارع، إنه مجرد
انهيار كامل لجميع البنية التحتية
والأزمة الإنسانية تزداد
سوءًا كل يوم، هل لديك أي
وضوح بشأن متى ستتمكن من جلب
الإمدادات الخاصة بك؟  كما
ذكرت، وهل أنت مسؤول عن
ضمان عدم وصول أي شيء آخر
إلى هناك، أعتقد أن أحد أكبر
المخاوف ربما سيكون أسلحة
لجنود حماس، هل أنت مسؤول
عن ضمان ما هو موجود بالفعل في تلك
الشاحنات، وليس الأمن المصري
والإسرائيلي؟  الأمن الأمم المتحدة
أي شخص آخر أه مسؤول
ويجب أن يكون مسؤولاً عن ضمان أن تكون أي
مساعدات قادمة إنسانية بحتة،
مهمتنا هي فقط شراء أي
إمدادات مطلوبة بناءً على ما
نعرفه عن الظروف على الأرض،
والعالم كله يعرف ما
الظروف على الأرض وقم
بشراء تلك المساعدات وإدخالها في
أسرع وقت ممكن، فالأمر لا يتعلق فقط بالمساعدات
القادمة ولكن دعونا نتذكر أيضًا أن
لدينا طبيبين أمريكيين هما الدكتورة
باربرا زين ورامونا أكامورا الذين
كانوا عالقين في غزة بالإضافة إلى العديد من الأطباء.
دوليون آخرون يحاولون الخروج أه
منذ بدء الإغلاق في 7 أكتوبر،
بالإضافة إلى أن هناك
المئات من الأطفال المصابين بجروح خطيرة
والذين يحتاجون إلى رعاية طبية لا
يمكنهم الحصول عليها محليًا ويجب
نقلهم لتلقي العلاج الطبي العاجل
كما  حسنًا، ينتظر المئات من
الأطفال المصابين في غزة الآن
نقل المتحولين لتلقي
العلاج الطبي، والعديد منهم سيموتون
إذا لم يحصلوا على هذا التحويل، لذا فإن
الأمر لا يقتصر على وصول المساعدات فحسب، بل يمثل أيضًا
فرصة إنسانية
ليحصل عليها الناس  خارج غزة، أعطنا إحساسًا
بأن ستيف، أنا أريد أن أتحدث عن
شعبك وخاصة
الموظفين الدوليين الموجودين
هناك في الوقت الحالي، ولكن فقط حتى
يفهم جمهوري
هدفك الأساسي قبل أن تبدأ الحرب، كانت
تساعدني كثيرًا  الأطفال المرضى يغادرون غزة
ويأتون إلى الولايات المتحدة لتلقي
العلاج. من الواضح أن كل ما توقف
في الوقت الحالي، فقط أعطنا فكرة عن
بعض التحديات التي
يواجهها الأطفال هناك بشكل جيد، التحديات التي
يواجهها الأطفال هي مجرد البقاء على قيد الحياة
و  نحن نتحدث عن مئات الآلاف
من الأطفال فقط للحصول على الغذاء والدواء
والمياه النظيفة التي أه لم تعد
متوفرة في معظمها في
قطاع غزة، هذه كلها تحديات أساسية
نأخذها كأمر مسلم به
منظمتنا قبل أن تبدأ هذه الجولة من
القتال  وبذلك كانت
المنظمة الرئيسية في العالم التي تجلب
فرقًا طبية تطوعية من جميع أنحاء
العالم وتوفر لآلاف
الأطفال في غزة
الرعاية الجراحية العاجلة المنقذة للحياة والمتغيرة للحياة في
المستشفيات المحلية، كما أننا
المنظمة الرئيسية التي ترسل الجرحى والمرضى
أطفال يخرجون للحصول على رعاية طبية مجانية، والعديد
منهم إلى الولايات المتحدة ويديرون
الكثير من البرامج والمشاريع الإنسانية الهامة الأخرى
على الأرض في
غزة بما في ذلك بناء
قسم سرطان الأطفال الأول والوحيد في غزة
والذي بالمناسبة استنفد
العلاج الكيميائي الآن  الأدوية ولم يعد
المرضى في ذلك القسم لا
يحصلون على أه العلاج الأساسي
لأمراضهم من السرطان الذي ينبغي أن
يحصلوا عليه وهذا يؤثر على العشرات
والعشرات من الأطفال المصابين بالسرطان في
قطاع غزة وكذلك كما ذكرت
من قبل حرفيا المئات  ومئات
من الأطفال المصابين ينتظرون نقلهم
خارج غزة للحصول على الرعاية الطبية. حسنًا،
لديك أطفال في هذه اللحظة
نفدت أدوية العلاج الكيميائي وليس هناك
ما يمكنك فعله فعليًا حتى
تأتي تلك الإمدادات. ستيف يتحدث إلى
أنهم ليسوا فقط  نفاد
أدوية السرطان، آسف، نفاد
الطعام أيضًا، لقد واجهنا صعوبة في
توصيل الطعام إلى قسم السرطان لدينا في
شمال مدينة غزة، فهو ممتلئ
بالمستشفى بأكمله، وهو مليء
باللاجئين الذين يبحثون عن مأوى هناك
على أمل ألا يتم قصفه كما
حدث في مستشفى الله، ولكن في هذا
القسم في مستشفى الأطفال
هناك انعدام للأمن الغذائي، ونواجه
صعوبة في توفير المياه النظيفة والغذاء
لمرضانا في هذا القسم، وليس
فقط أدوية العلاج الكيميائي